اضعفنا الاقتصاد الروسي
يا رسول الله
دبلوماسيه للشرق الاوسط والرصاص الافريقيا
اغلى صفقه طرفاها امريكا وايران وطرف ثالث
يعمل من خلف الستار العم سام يعلنها لان
قاع في نفس الحفره مرتين وطهران ترد العين
ليست بالعين خمسه امريكيين يساوون الكثير
واشنطن تتبع اسلوب السياسه الناعمه
وتتفادى الانزلاق في وحل الشرق الاوسط
بينما في افريقيا تتبع سياسه العين
الحمراء وتعلينها سنحول غرب افريقيا الى
بركه دماء كيف كسر خمسه امريكيين انفا
العم سامي الطويل وما هي اغلى صفقه تبادل
اسرى تكبدت امريكا امام طموح ايران وهل
ستشهد الايام القادمه تقاربا بين واشنطن
وطهران وكيف تحاول واشنطن التظاهر
بالسلميه في الشرق الاوسط بينما تدفع
الامور في افريقيا الى غياب حرب عالميه
ربما ستكتبو نهايه العالم لتعرف اجابه كل
تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو للنهايه لو
ذراعي واشنطن
اقتربت ملحمه انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه
شعبيه جو بايدن على المحك بعد ان ضاعت في
عهده الهيبه الامريكيه وسقط ماء وجه
واشنطن على اثر صفحات الدب الروسي
المتكرره بايدن يحتاج الى طوق نجاه اي
انجاز حتى وان كان بسيطا ربما ينقذ الموقف
وهنا وجد ضالته في ايران التي تضم سجونها
معتقلين امريكيين ولابد من ان يحررهم
بايدن ليصبح بطلا في نظر الشعب الامريكي
لم تجرا واشنطن على استخدام القوه مع
طهران فيا لا تريد ان تسقط في نفس الحفره
مرتين ونقصد هنا واقعه احتجاز موظفي
السفاره الامريكيه في طهران عام 79 ووضع
هيبه امريكا في وضع حرج اذ حاولوا تحريرهم
بالقوه المسلحه ولكن تحول الامر الى فضيحه
مدويه للبيت الابيض
فقد لجا بايدن الى السياسه الناعمه او
الدبلوماسيه الحذره فلم يكن امامه اي خيار
اخر
صفقه مهينه
عماني متصلان من المفاوضات السريه بين
واشنطن وظهران من اجل افراج الاخيره عن
خمسه اسرى يحملون الجنسيه الامريكيه
والذين تم احتجازهم في سجن ايفين سيء
السمعه مقابل ان تفرج واشنطن عن خمسه اسرع
رابنين من السجون الامريكيه ولكن الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي يعلنها مدويه
الثمن ليس كافيا خمسه امريكيين يسابون
الكثير يا ابناء العم سام خمسه اسرى
ايرانيين لم يكونوا كافيين لملا عين طهران
فطلبت المزيد وكان لها ما ارادت فقد تم
الاتفاق على ان تفرج طهران عن خمسه سجناء
امريكيين ومن المفارقات ان هؤلاء السجناء
من اصول ايرانيه ايضا وفي المقابل تخرج
واشنطن عن خمسه سجناء ايرانيين وماذا
والافراج ايضا عن سته مليارات دولار تخص
طهران جمدتها بنوك كوريا الجنوبيه تنفيذا
للعقوبات المفروضه على ايران اي ان ايران
ستحصل على خمسه من سجنيها بالاضافه الى
سته مليارات دولار ربما لم تكن ستحصل علي
لولا هذا الاتفاق بدا طهران في تنفيذ
الخطوه الاولى فقد نقلت السجناء
الامريكيين من سجن ايفين ووضعتهم تحت
الاقامه الجبريه باحد الفنادق والان جاء
دور واشنطن لتفرج عن السجناء الايرانيين
وتفرج ايضا عن السته مليارات دولار لصالح
طهران بالطبع اتفاق كهذا من الممكن ان
يهيج الشارع الامريكي ضد بايدن ياتي
بنتائج عكسيه لذا فقد لجا بايدن الى اسلوب
اللف
فرغم ان تفاصيل تنفيذ الاتفاق لم تعلن
بشكل رسمي بعد هناك مصادر عديده قالت ان
السته مليارات دولار لن تدخل في حسابات
البنوك الايرانيه بشكل مباشر حتى لا
تستفيد منها طهران الا فيما تحدده لها
الاداره الامريكيه وغالبا سيتم نقل تلك
الاموال من بنوك كوريا الجنوبيه الى
امريكا او سويسرا ومنها الى بنوك قطر ومن
قطر تستطيع ايران صرفه تلك الاموال في
شراء سلع انسانيه فقط كالغذاء والدواء واي
سلع اساسي لا تدخل في دعم برنامجها النووي
او التسليح ولكن ياتي الصوت من طرف مجهول
الامر ليس بهذه السهوله يا بايدن وطريقك
لفتره رئاسيه جديده لن يكون مفروشا
بالحرير فحتى يدخل هذا الاتفاق حيز
التنفيذ من جانب واشنطن لابد من ان يقره
الكونجرس الامريكي وه تكمن الازمه مجلس
الشيوخ الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون بالطبع
سيعرقل هذا الاتفاق من اجل احراج بيض
وحزبه الديمقراطي كما ان بعض الديمقراطيين
انفسهم لا يميلون الى تنفيذ مثل هذا
الاتفاق خصوصا مع عدو كايران ناهيك عن ان
الجو العام نفسه مشحون بالتوتر فمنذ فتره
قصيره ارسلت واشنطن حشودا عسكريه الى مضيق
هرمز زعيمه انها تواجه تهديدات ايرانيه في
المنطقه الصفقه مهدده بالفشل وطوق نجاتك
يا بيض مهدد بالضياع ولكن على ايه حال فان
قضيه الاسره تعد من النوادر التي تتواصل
فيها ايران واداره امريكيه الى حل بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه وان كانت اتفاقا مبدئيا وهنا
السؤال ماذا لو نجح بايدن في اقناع
الكونجرس وتنفيذ الصفقه هل يمكن ان تكون
تلك القضيه بدايه لرفع العقوبات
الاقتصاديه
وتصفيه خلافاتها مع امريكا وتبدا طهران
وواشنطن صفحه جديده لن نغامر بالتصالح
يبدو ان قضيه الاسرار لن تكون كافيه
لتحريك الماء الراكد بين طهران واشنطن حتى
وان نجحت وسيستمر الغداء بين البلدين
لعقود اخرى اذا لم تحدث معجزه تقضي على
هذا الغداء فقد اعلنها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه صراحه في اي حال من الاحوال لن
تحصل ايران على اي تخفيف للعقوبات سيتم
استخدام الاموال الايرانيه وتحويلها الى
حسابات مقيده بحيث لا يمكن استخدام ايران
لتلك الاموال الا للاغراض الانسانيه وهو
ما يسمح به بموجب عقوباتنا وكان بلينكن
يقول هذه نقره وهذه نقره لا تقارب مع
ايران وكل اتفاق له ظروفه تظن يا عزيزي ان
الضباع واشنطن اصبحت اليفه وتميل لحل
ازماتها بالطرق السلميه والدليل على ذلك
هو صبرهم على المفاوضات مع ايران عدم
لجوهم الى القوه العسكريه من اجل تحرير
سجنائهم ولكن الهدا الضباع واشنطن والغرب
حقا
الكيل بمكيالين دعني اقول لك يا عزيزي ان
الامريكان لا يتركون السلاح جانبا الا
مرغمين بل ويطبقون مقوله العقل للاقوياء
والرصاص للضعفاء ففي الوقت الذي شجع فيه
مع ايران كان هو نفسه اول الداعمين
لمجموعه اكواس التي تنوي التدخل عسكريا في
النيجر لاعاده بازون حليف الغرب على راس
السلطه بل وكانت واشنطن وباريس وما من
دفعت لاتخاذ مثل هذا القرار لاخافه باقي
افريقيا فبرغم ان كان ينادي بالحل
لم يعلن ولو لمره واحده رفضه للتدخل
العسكري في النيجر واليوم بدات جيوش دول
مجموعه اكواس في الانتشار بالفعل
والاستعداد لحرب في النيجر دفاعا عن مصالح
امريكا وفرنسا وبدعم قوي من البلدين ايضا
لا يهم كم شخصا سيروح ضحيه لهذه الحرب بل
وربما تتحول الى حرب عالميه بالفعل ولا
يهم حجم الخسائر التي ستتكبدها القاره
السمراء ما يهم هو مصلحه واشنطن فقط التي
من اجلها يسقط قناع عن سام ويظهر وجهه
الحقيقي والسؤال لكم مشاهدينا هل سينجح
بايدن في صفقته مع ايران ويظهر امام شعبه
كالبطل فمن الجمهوريين سيكون لهم راي اخر
اخبرونا في صندوق التعليقات
[موسيقى]